[Musique]
boulogne boulogne boulogne boulogne
boulogne billancourt
qu'est ce qui à boulogne billancourt il
ya plein d'entreprises il ya instable il
ya plein de chance mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de marques de smartphones dont
une qu'on va les voir aujourd'hui c'est
repos
j'imagine que vous connaissez au projet
déjà parlé avec plein de smartphones
peuvent solution quant au choix d'un
récent est aujourd'hui rendue il ya
quelques jours aux dons lancé un dernier
de leur petit bébé de leurs gardes
il ya eu le finepix il ya deux ans il me
semble et aujourd'hui c'est le finepix 2
et le finepix de fraude paquet présent
lors du lancement
donc maintenant de sa session de
rattrapage ça c'est la nouveauté et le
haut peau fine x2 promo des crocodiles
fabien est en précommande à thorzain
merci aussi jeu très content de te voir
on est dans les locaux de au pot ici à
boulogne billancourt pour voir le
nouveautés produits justement alors il
ya deux nouveautés produits mais six ans
françois prudent ça c'est ça en fait on
a lancé nouvelle gamme très haut de
gamme de chez aux pauvres donc la gamme
fans ouais il ya deux produits le fanis
de pro et le fas mx2 oui mais en france
on n'en sera que le famille de pro vous
lancer le plus haut de gamme le plus le
meilleur ski ce lieu c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'il raconte ce smartphone comme
l'histoire aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya
la nouvelle le nouveau segment qui va
avoir lieu en 2011 ce vraiment là
l'écran la photo la batterie sans goût
les trois groupes moins forte sur
lesquels des constructeurs en mettre
l'accent en rose que tu veux ça des
grandes qualités pour le dédier regarder
dans un confort fin de la photo pour
aller les souvenirs et puis ton
smartphone y cache pas au bout de dix
minutes c'est ça je me parle de très
beaux résultats
juste pour vous montrer il existe en
deux finitions coup une finition noire
qui en céramique haute densité donc des
matériaux au niveau de gamme et la
céramique je me permets de te coupent le
service qui m'a dit qu'il y avait un
petit côté un peu avec 10 touchés avec
la petite streak oms a donc été coterie
ou toucher c'est un léger c'est à la
fois sévèrement soyeuse et un petit côté
et brisant je sais pas moi le sens où le
doigt on sent le petit relief est sympa
et une seconde finitions en cuir les
hyènes donc peut-être un petit peu plus
fini
mincom couleurs mais un côté un peu chic
voilà côté un peu chic kervegan faillite
je me permets c'est pas toi qui lis
c'est moi qui le dit le cuir vegan ça
n'existe pas si ces dégâts ne s'est pas
un animal donc c'est ça il m'a donc ce
que c'est du polyuréthane donc c'est à
base de passer un petit synthétique sans
critiquer le produit donc il ya un
aspect cuir donc il ya un côté un peu
chic mais on n'est pas sûr de la dette
première chose c'est le l'écran le fait
que c'est un écran 120 hertz qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement ça veut
dire que ça va être vous allez à une
fluidité de navigation qui va être
extrêmement agréable par exemple si vous
faites défiler une page web
ça va permettre d'avoir un image hyper
fluide alors moi je me mets dans les
paramètres de base
je vois que de base il est sélectionné
sur paille je me mets la section
automatiquement donc ça veut dire qu'ils
à switcher entre le 60 hertz et le sens
vers ce qu'on peut sélectionner chacun
manuellement si on souhaite c'est ça
mais lui de façon intelligente et va
venir sélectionné ce qui correspond au
mieux tomber un gars comme moi là oui
tout à fait parce qu'évidemment le sens
inverse à un petit inconvénient c'est
que ça a consommé un petit peu plus
d'énergie pour la batterie là vous avez
un mode en fait qu'il va switcher
automatiquement entre 2 60 et 120 selon
le scénario du visage alors j'ai vu
aussi vous aviez en termes de résolution
de l'écran on va pouvoir soit être
pareil sur un mode automatique soit il
sur dué fhd plus 2376 parmi 80 joly
c'est écrit là j'oublie ch soit du cube
des plus 3160 en 1440 on sait à quel
moment ça va swinguer pareil lorsque tu
as besoin de d'une d'une meilleure
résolution sur une partie des ming sur
un visionnage comme ça alors ça ça va
dépendre effectivement du fichier source
aussi il va sélectionner à faire une
sélection c'est automatique après le ski
est intéressant de noter c'est que le
puits hd + est également pris en charge
par le sens à l'acte oui j'ai lu on va
le prendre en charge la mer la meilleure
définition possible même ensemble ça
veut dire que je suis engagé au cul hd
plus et on s'en va hertz autonomie
d'abaisser légèrement ou drastiquement
paris laissait quand vous allez à
quantifier south est aujourd'hui à paris
j'ai pas de chiffres à donner là dessus
mais vraiment savourer le plus faire le
test
bon ça on le verra lors du test on vous
invite dès maintenant à vous abonner
comme ça vous serez tous parce qu'on
aura la très prochainement ok donc ça
c'est vachement cool en rien un truc
c'est le moteur c'est quoi ces 01 ou
oui alors moi je les trouve ça c'est la
version le nom anglais mais
effectivement pour que ça parle un petit
peu plus moi je les appelais plus de
traitement du signal fin du signal vidéo
ouais en fait c'est une puce qui va
servir à deux choses c'est ce qu'on
retrouve sur des télés haut de gamme
c'est pour ça que c'est pour l'instant
ça n'existe nulle part sur le sur les
smartphones c'est tout seul à faire ça
mais pour l'instant se placer une puce
qui développé par au pot et qui va
permettre de faire de la compensation de
mouvement vidéo
quand je changerais je regarder une
vidéo en streaming par exemple et que
l'image est en 30 images par seconde
jusqu'à val convertir en 60 qui a permet
d'avoir une vidéo alors séparé s'édifie
s'est expliquée comme ça c'est compliqué
mais il faut voir il faut le voir ça à
voir on va voir une vidéo qui sera plus
fluide plus agréable à regarder
donc lors de ces trois paramètres qui
sont à la gaming paraissait intéressant
aussi
oui oui tu te mon sens inverse non cash
de plus il captive cela je veux dire tu
es summum de ce qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui sur un smartphone
c'est un petit point important pour le
cette puce sait qu'elle va elle est
compatible avec les plateformes netflix
amazon prime est également youtube pour
convertir du coup le contenu vidéo en
faire un obscur du contenu vidéo avoir
une expérience la meilleure fluidité
le mode anti sentiment aussi je te le
mode qui s'appelle anti scintillement
être utilisée par deux sentiments
ressentis sentiment si par exemple que
je me mets ici en très très basse
luminosité
je vais avoir un écran avec des espèces
de banques qui vont apparaître wiki pour
les personnes sensibles ça peut ça peut
fatiguer les yeux ici en activant le
supprimer c'est ben ouais c'est marrant
pour réduire la fatigue oculaire et on
s'en rend pas compte comme ça c'est
vraiment une envie ça vraiment voir avec
un autre smartphone pour hockey génial
une chose que j'ai pas dit fectivement
c'était que si on essaie également le
premier écran du marché 10 bits qui veut
dire qu'il est capable d'afficher un
milliard de couleurs contre 16,7
millions et le standard actuel qu'on
retrouve sur les smartphones d'accord on
qui va permettre aussi d'avoir un
contenu vidéo encore plus nuancée plus
riches
on a également la certification hdr 10
plus qui permet de regarder dans la
meilleure qualité possible contenu sur
netflix par exemple je viens je n'ai pas
de commission spécialement pour eux le
ratio l'écran c'est quoi ces deux c'est
du vin deviennent alors presque 19
points 8 sur 19 points 8 est la partie
audio haut parleurs stéréo pour parleurs
stéréo ouais comme une qualité donc en
haut en bas des pistes et bien
évidemment pour aller avec un monument
est ici ok ça risque jack
à noter c'est à dire un standard
aujourd'hui sur les cimes téléphones
haut de gamme c'est bien très plus en
plus rares ont eu tous 5.1 tu me disais
pour venir brancher un casque
oui il ya des facteurs qui font diaries
pour brancher un casque vous avez un
casque on décide il ya un castrum usb
sata quid de la performance on est sur
un terrain flagship donc il ya tout ce
qui se fait de mieux snapdragon 865 5g à
la plateforme la plus puissante de chez
qualcomm la dernière technologie de ram
qui va permettre notamment pour l'ailier
moeurs de profiter d'une intense
chargement des jeux plus rapide
ep délire 5 c ca 12 giga de ram 512
stockage native tu peux pas voir en
dessous vincent ledoux ce soit 100 m
c'est une version 512 mo extensible non
extensible hockey et à 12 giga de ram
tapas de 8000 adrian n'a pas de version
en dessous non il est est ce que tu as
besoin nécessairement d'avoir douze igad
rapaces côté sur une version 5 gs qui a
un lien ou pas c'est plutôt en prévision
du futur où effectivement les
applications tout ce qu'on a accusé en 5
j a potentiellement de plus en plus
d'applications depuis dix ans qu'ils
vont être plus demandeuses d'énergie aux
gourmands des moments il faut anticiper
ce problème en moins c'est plus pour
anticiper et puis va offrir vraiment le
feu qui s'est tenue actuellement quoi ok
ça ne lui fit 6
même les petits détails qui peut être
intéressant aussi qui va permettre de
notamment sur des réseaux comme les et
les aéroports ou des endroits comme ça
qui sont un peu saturé parfois le wifi
schiste va apporter un vrai plus pour
profiter d'un débit accéléré quasiment
indépendant pour chaque connexion le
transfert c'est de lui et fès 3.3.1 le
feu se propage au mexique la recharge
alors tu me disais que vous avez une
recharge qui déchirait tout vous avez un
bloc de charge qui hésiteront ce que je
me permets pas de douche à un notebook
si mr sur le truc vous êtes déjà hyper
balèze en termes de charge rapide et ça
ça excuse moi la tête du téléphone c'est
pas humain ce truc est pas humain
on va chercher quoi 65 watts et 165
watts ce qui permet quoi de charger le
téléphone à 60% 15 minutes
oui et à 100% en 38 minutes ils sont
contents de 0 à 100% en 38 minutes
le pourcentage est affiché avec même la
virgule derrière tu dois montrer on peut
voir monter très rapidement c'est assez
impressionnant pour vous rassurer c'est
une seule charge qui restent à basse
tension ce qui veut dire que ça va
éviter de faire chauffer la matrice est
une charge qui est aussi beaucoup plus
sûr du fait qu'elle est basse tension
est ce que tu as des chiffres ans
patrice autonomie ou alors ça on verra
vraiment hors du test sur l'autonomie
ce concept devoir prendre pour le test
nous ce qu'on garantisse et une journée
d'étude d'utilisation ce qui aujourd'hui
le portrait des bandas c'est une honte
je peux pas dire - fait pas du bien pour
l'avenir - après voilà ce qui est le
gros point fort c'est vraiment la
recharge qui va permettre de retrouver
mon com 10 et 60 % à 15 minutes
donc après évidemment tout dépend de
l'utilisation si je suis en 5 j 1 100
mariant ce que je fais avec mon
téléphone mais un jour une utilisation
n'est pas tout si tu veux quand même sur
une capacité de 4000 260 millions perd
donc ce qui est comme une 4260 60
millions offerts ici tu as oublié de le
recharger
si tu arrive le matin qui a le plus
grand chose tu prends tu va te laver tu
reviens il est vrai ça c'est magnifique
mais moi ce qui m'impressionne vachement
ses salles à la taille des objectifs
c'est juste à point hallucinant alors
raconte moi qu'est ce que ça raconte
tout ça je vais commencer par par le
capteur principal qui est quand même la
pièce unique de ce smartphone
ouais c'est que c'est un capteur sony
qui a été développée customisé pour
repos alors c'est au pot qui a donné un
cahier des charges à sony pour
développer ce capteur donc on est les
premiers à l'avoir scellier 1689
pour ceux qui s'y intéressent et il a
plusieurs particularités pour les
amateurs de photos c'est le premier
capteur sur smartphone qui est capable
de tirer des images en 12 bits donc en
fichier avant la corne qui va permettre
de retraités la photo après coup le bo
s'impose prod derrière sur le service de
qualité
tu as plein d'informations qui sont
stockés dans ta photo nature c'est ça
c'est ça alors évidemment ça les photos
on prend un petit peu plus de place sur
le smartphone
fatalement mais voilà pour pour des
amateurs de photos c'est un sa peau est
un vrai plus l'autre point fort de ce
capteur c'est que par rapport à des
capteurs standards du marché là on a
augmenté nettement la taille du capteur
la taille des pixels ce qui va permettre
d'absorber plus de lumière donc c'est
aussi un des critère principal qui fait
qu'on peut faire des bonnes photos ok et
l'autre point fort c'est aussi une
première sur smartphone c'est
l'autofocus en fait c'est un technologie
d'autofocus ou 100% des pixels servent à
faire la mise au point d'accord contre
3% sur un capteur ce temps là qu'est ce
que ça apporte concrètement c'est quand
je veux faire une photo de nuit parce
qu'aujourd'hui deux jours ont quasiment
tout le monde et faire tout le monde
sait faire tout ne sait faire une mise
au point tout sont tous et faire de
bonnes photos de nuit là la mise au
point va être très rapide très précise
et je peux la faire sur des objets même
en 2d et 3d ça va
enfin l'arrière-plan l'avant-plan c'est
très facile à faire
tiens d'abord à dire un critère
supplémentaire pour faire des bonnes
photos nues d'accord on est sur un
capteur de combien de mégapixels 48,48
kessel capteur principal +48 mégapixels
grand-angle les ouvertures ckoi 1.72
point j'ai un doute 2.2 et 3.0 sur le
téléobjectif il risque au pit bike au
pic ok ça marche alors ultra grand-angle
c'est le lit et mixe 586 en terme de
deux capteurs donc c'est ce qu'on
retrouvait en capteur principal du rhino
zoom x 10 qui était quand même l'ancien
flexible de chez opodo donc aussi très
bon en photo donc on a un très belle
définition en grand-angle
la petite nouveauté c'est qu'on y
ajouter le mode vidéo ultra stable
oui donc aujourd'hui maintenant je suis
capable d'avoir donc ce mode dans avec
deux capteurs le capteur principal et le
grand-angle tu me disais que là dessus
tu avais pas de stabilisation optique
ses utilisations en numérique si tu veux
de l'optique sur le capteur principal
allié de la stab optique fouet et sur le
thé l'objectif y en a aussi
yann oui ça va forcément c'était
l'objectif c'est un zoom optique x 5 qui
peut aller jusqu à la fois dix ans
hybride pour qu'ils me permettre de
conserver une qualité d'image qui est
quand même très très bonne et je
m'entends combien maximum 60 ans
numérique ouais bon après voilà c'est du
zoom numérique
c'est toujours un peu pour le côté un
peu ces points c'est plus le côté
amusant on peut s'amuser un peu avec
mais c'est pas forcément là par exemple
là je vais chez les voisins voilà les
rideaux sont tirés ne vous inquiétez pas
je ne pars pas c'est juste pour tester
les problèmes ça est quand même toujours
très impressionnant je suis persuadé que
pour l'instrument fait rien mais ça
manque l'innovation cette capacité
d'innover mais effectivement les
messieurs sur un smartphone ceccaldi pc
c'est vraiment très très impressionnant
ok génial donc ça c'est vachement cool
on a un petit laser aussi qui est
planqué oui petit focus laser qu'il faut
que je vais être un support
supplémentaire pour le taux focus déjà
très bon du capteur principal d'accor 2
dans la nuit ou si tu y vas qui va
porter à un avantage supplémentaire
ok et dernier point du coup tête du cac
à peu près ça va être la l'interface
kolo reste donc on est sur un but de
couper la vidéo on pour que tu me dises
rapidement on peut donc avoir une
stabilisation est également derrière une
stabilisation logiciel oui là dessus on
en parle en fait de 20 ans
je peux donc avoir pareil une stable sur
le capteur sur le grand angle et sur le
capteur principal je peux filmer au
maximum encore 4 k4 alors sur la sur l'
ultra stable sur ce mode là c'est 1080p
maximum d'accord parce que je viens kron
p sinon si je rêve là ça ce sens ce mode
là tu peux aller jusqu'à 4/4 en 60
images par seconde tubize et coloriste
les nouveaux des coloris est ce donc un
certain nombre de nouveautés alors
l'interface a été complètement revu
ouais déjà pour optimiser l'utilisation
l'utilisation à une main parce
qu'effectivement les soirs de téléphone
qui font comme une certaine taille avec
un écran de 6 à u 7 pouces donc là on a
une optimisation en fait qui est fait de
manière à ce que les icônes soit placé
idéalement pour que tout soit accessible
à une main et on a eu un certain nombre
d'améliorations aussi en termes de
d'effets visuels
toutes les animations ont été revus avec
la personnalisation des icônes ça c'est
vraiment sympa notamment pour des
personnes qui potentiellement viendrait
achète un impôt pour la première fois
ouais il n'aime pas trop le style des
icônes mais là je peux vraiment
complètement le personnaliser le tout
faire je peux en avant des rondes et
carrées des passes qui est dingue c'est
que tu vas complètement redessiné les
icônes d
des différents quelles que soient les
échos donc on s'en fiche tu fais ce que
tu veux tu peux modifier toutes les
tailles la taille à l'intérieur la
taille et le contour ses banques ou de
génial je crois que mes rentes openshaw
d'alors n'a pas la question c'est quand
est-ce que ce smartphone devrait être
disponible et surtout combien auraient
payé parce que avec toutes les
techniques ont à l'intérieur que
j'imagine il n'est pas gratuit il n'est
pas gratuit effectivement il sera lancée
au prix de 1199 ou 1199 euros il ya une
seule confie il ya donc un seul tarif
ouais ok ça marche 500 bougies en
mémoire 12 il ya drame comme on disait
tout à l'heure et disponible courant mai
sachant qu'il ya effectivement je fais
un petit peu de teasing parce que c'est
pas encore annoncé mais il y aura
d'autres produits dans cette gamme qui
seront à des tarifs plus alors de quel
typologie de produits ne veut pas dire
quoi oui plus avoir des produits sont
des produits apple fan x-series donc
donc on reste dans smartphones vont
rester dans ce nombre est en baisse donc
droit à une déclinaison de smartphones à
ce moment on en reparlera quand ces
produits ont c'est pas bientôt fin avril
enfin oui on se reverra
c'est bien de savoir à combien ces
banques est super et ben écoute très
joli produit qui fait plein de jolies
promesses
j'ai hâte de le tester comme ça je
pourrais donner mon retour donc vous
habite maintenant à vous abonner s'est
pas déjà le cas parce que ça c'est
vachement intéressant il pas ce que vous
entendez comment vous les trouvez vous
ces smartphones avec le côté céramique
et cuir mais gagnent tellement dites moi
comment voulez trouver près de marquer
ça en banque comme un tapis si vous avez
des questions et si vous avez des choses
que vous voulez que je vois et je teste
en particulier justement lors du test
qui arrivera dans quelques temps que
pour l'instant ça c'est pas les versions
de face les proto ça c'est des
prototypes fixer les proto on est
quasiment sûr la version définitive mais
pas tout à fait on les reçoit caen s'est
produit pour tester mais très bientôt
bientôt j attends donc si vous avez des
questions sur le test des questions
particulier chose que vous voulez que je
vois ce n'est marqué en bas en
commentaire je le regarderai en détails
et je vous dirai tout au long du test
sur ce je vous embrasse
à bientôt après cinquante années donc
merci râler de l'amour flou
[Musique]